upwards of 70 percent of lottery winners
go bankrupt
wow millions and millions of dollars and
they go bankrupt they lose everything
wow because of two reasons number one
they did not come up with a plan for
their money
in all those millions and millions of
dollars did was magnify who they already
were and who they already were with
someone who just spins recklessly and
spends money they don't got and takes
out loans and gets whatever they want
doesn't say no and all that stuff
the second reason people who win the
lottery go bankrupt is they're
surrounded by leeches
people who want a piece and want a peace
and want a peace